let's see this cats fan he was pretty
hyped uh when
dustin got the finish come on come on
baby
he's shirtless
wow you can't have your shirt on and
[ __ ] love dustin diamond poirier i'm
gonna go ahead and say that right now
bro
okay i was completely naked by the end
of the fight
theo what are you going to do with this
money doug what are you going to do with
the grand
with that granddaughter try sniffing it
daddy
let me think what i like to do bro might
get my face done or something might get
a little botox bruh
all right botox why don't you but once
you buy some of uh dustin poury's hot
sauce a thousand dollars worth of his
hot sauce they don't have to fight
anymore
you know what i already i already have
about 150 worth down downstairs right
now
uh let me think what i'll do you know
what i'm gonna do man i'm gonna buy i'm
gonna donate 500
to the good fight foundation right now
so i'll put that out there
and then the other 500 i might give me a
couple of necklaces from kohl's
[Laughter]
oh i got to send you my text too nick
that brent that uh dustin sent me
well that was a that was a nice flex
right there
oh they're tight they're tight i want to
have michael chandler and dustin poirier
in the next this past weekend hopefully
calling in
here's what i got it's sunday at 2 54
a.m it's at tell brennan b-r-e-n-n-a-n
he owes he's in dubai hasn't slept he
knows how to spell my name
no i don't think look and dustin will be
the first one to tell you spelling name
really is [ __ ] you know
his forte you know but he said tell
brennan
he said tell brennan he owes you some
cash maybe that's what he said
you bet against yeah yeah why'd you
better get yeah that's a great question
eric thank you
why'd you bet against somebody i'm
closer with douglas because you were so
confident on it
i wasn't that confident i kept telling
theo i was like doug if you're going to
bet on this not bad a bet on dustin
because
vegas has it three to one this is a good
fight man connor hasn't fought
but you bet him because it's fun for the
show
i actually wanted better more too and i
was like i'll bring cash down whatever
you want to do
all right so you have now i appreciate
the best that seems like a soft answer
right there that seems like a
back-peddling
answer yeah a little bit just say you
think he's a [ __ ] just say it
just say it right to just write on
camera get it get it out cause you
having zuma
zuma right now you didn't think he had
it in him anymore
no he was crazy dude did he he seemed
angry after the fight did you
you sense that a little bit brendan yeah
i think so the
the disrespect right like they're like
oh we fight chandler next he's like
what are we doing he's like challenged
to be the guy i already beat
you know how the you look at my body of
work it's like give me the goddamn belt
and he's not getting paid like the guys
that he's fighting right so he
he fought khabib khabib made more money
than god
pouring lost that fight but got paid
[ __ ] he fights conor carter makes more
money than god dustin gets [ __ ] over
there again so
i think he's just sick of it well i mean
yeah i agree but don't have good but
isn't it the business
isn't that the entertainment portion of
it that just there's no
fairness in it conor mcgregor's the name
whoever he fights is going to make a lot
of money
right there's yes so there's there is
fairness
within it's same as comedy like there's
market value
so how many tickets you sell on the road
is how much money you're getting i know
i know but
i'm not saying so okay but that's a good
review i don't know but that's why he
makes more money i know but that's a
good example
because what this guy is saying is i'm
funnier than that guy
i'm clearly a better comedian but the
market value is this other guy
yeah they're saying you might be better
right right that's what i'm saying more
people are paying money to see this guy
right right you're gonna pay this guy
more so so
he's so that's what i'm saying is he
needs to understand that it doesn't work
about
like they people don't get paid based
off their skill value they get paid
based off like
whatever the thing is yeah it and it's
kind of a shame because
you know the ufc is a sport because in
the nfl or nba
you know if you're the best player in
the game you're going to be competing
like the best player in the game
right yeah in the ufc you're talking
about or even for that [ __ ]
yeah but then does that mean they don't
get paid but does that mean that ufc is
not
um it's not run say
it's based more on that than it is like
like like a
a fair and equitable way of doing it
right yeah
like it's like there's a league and it's
like you have seatings and it's like if
you have this thing to do though like
like dustin poirier is ranked number two
connor's number four because they care
about that
no not really yeah it's more around like
the wwe shouldn't it be like a
tournament like it starts there should
be a fight season
and then it's like er er you fight
certain a number of fights for the
entire year and then it's like oh we
have the number one seed
versus this and then they have a pot at
the end of the year they do that in
uh world series or what was it pfl the
pfl does that on the espn
prize nobody i never even heard of it so
that's why it's not there you go i was
just going to say nobody knows what that
is
you're watching this show that sounds
like like it's bad like the filipino
league or something
it just doesn't seem i think he also
said you know that they had two weeks
where they were
just sitting there stuck in that place
man that must have been we got a
quarantine he can't leave the room
yeah and then you know and then it's
it's the with this on the island yeah
uh abu dhabi but the island's great what
a good idea they can't leave though
i mean the island's not this city block
i'm sure it's
well no they can't they can't even go
out they can't leave their hotel room oh
they're like stuck in there yeah but how
much money did he get
750 i thought i saw plus so plus they
get a bonus so
he'll he'll make he'll make over a mill
okay so for a million dollars you could
stay in your hotel room for a few years
in my hotel right yeah you know it's not
like yeah cry me a river
yeah an hour
he ain't working at kohl's in tennessee
you know what i mean they hit in the
face so you got a little
this is great bro but hey man
i think they got to give the man the
belt who else is he going to fight you
know what i'm saying get
paid a man dana paid a man
you know what on behalf of king in this
thing i'm gonna take that thousand i'm
gonna donate the whole thing to good
fight foundation man i'm sorry for being
cheap bro
let's go let's go i'm gonna donate 200
to 40 foundation let's get rocky out
here
[Music]